I have total family size Envy right now  you know I got I got married we got  started a little bit later I I hope to  catch up I think uh as just a matter of  biology I'm not quite sure we could get  up to eight biological children though  you've adopted as well now your family  size is unusual by today's stand by  historical standards it's not but by  modern liberal Society standards it  certainly is what has impelled you to  have such a large family God  simply answer the God I mean it was  never our plan to have a big family  um but my husband was military and we  traveled around the world and our oldest  son kept praying for a brother and they  just kept coming so there we go three  girls the little girls of seven seven  boys we wouldn't have it any other way  though like our life is crazy and  chaotic and amazing and beautiful  [Music]